[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD DEVAUL:
The actual Moonshot
is wonderful, inspirational,
poetic, beautiful, involved,
great technical challenges,
genuine heroism--
it brought the world together.
But think about the
Polynesian islander,
on a dugout canoe,
deciding one day
they were going to go that way.
No one had ever been
that way before.
No one even knew if there was
anything that way, before.
It was amazing.
And it changed the world.
ASTRO TELLER: People
can set their minds
to magical, seemingly
impossible ideas.
And then, through
science and technology,
bring them to reality.
And that, then sets
other people on fire.
Then other things
that look impossible
might be accomplishable.
JOHN F. KENNEDY
(VOICEOVER): Many years ago,
the great British
explorer, George Mallory,
who was to die on
Mount Everest, was
asked, why did he
want to climb it?
He said, because it is there.
RICHARD DEVAUL: Everyone
else in the world
is working on that next 10%.
If you could be the one
that delivers that 10 times
improvement, you have a chance
to really change things.
ASTRO TELLER
(VOICEOVER): If you want
cars to run at 50
miles per gallon, fine,
you can retool your
car a little bit.
But if I tell you it has
to run on a gallon of gas
for 500 miles, you
have to start over.
MEGAN SMITH: You need a lot
of courage in this work,
and you need a lot
of persistence.
Even if you don't
really, 100% believe
it's possible-- like
you might think,
this might be possible--
have the courage to try.
That's how the greatest
things have happened.
ASTRO TELLER: You don't spend
your time being bothered
that you can't teleport from
here to Japan, because there's
a part of you that
thinks it's impossible.
Moonshot thinking is choosing
to be bothered by that.
JOHN F. KENNEDY
(VOICEOVER): We choose
to go to the moon
in this decade,
and do the other things.
Not because they are easy,
but because they are hard.
RICHARD DEVAUL:
Humanity's progress
has been a series of
amazing audacious things,
from the very
small and personal,
up to the great, big and grand.
And we are a species
of Moonshots.
And to me, that's like
the really amazing, poetic
inspirational thing.
MEGAN SMITH: When you find your
passion, you're unstoppable.
You can make amazing
things happen.
It's been true through
all of history.
When Kennedy said that we
would put a man on the moon,
it's about the
fact that he said,
we don't know how
to do this yet,
and we're going to do it anyway.
And that sends chills
up everybody's spine.
Because if that happens,
what couldn't we do?
MEGAN SMITH: Welcome to
Solve for X. I'm Megan Smith,
and this is--
[APPLAUSE]
I have a fan down there.
And Puneet Ahira.
And when we started Solve for
X, the idea of it-- actually,
the original crazy idea was
that when we had begun Google X,
we were looking for projects.
And we were going to have
a conference to brainstorm.
And so we started thinking
about the conference.
And then we had way too
many ideas for Google X,
and there was no way
we could do anymore.
But we decided to still
have the conference.
And the reason for that is,
there is extraordinary people
all around the world.
And there always have been.
Who just are inspired, and
taking these moonshots,
and really trying to make the
world better, in radical ways.
And many of them
are techies like us.
And so we wanted to have a place
where we can celebrate people
who are in the middle of trying.
Not when they're in history
books later, because they get
celebrated.
But in the middle of trying.
You know that moment for like,
Elon Musk-- I don't know,
about five years ago, when
people were like the rockets
are blowing up.
Tesla, how is it
going to make money?
You know, that just
no one believed.
And he needed help then.
And I feel like those are
the people that Solve for X
are really about.
We call them these
Moonshot Pioneers.
And the structure of a
Moonshot, in our mind, of a tech
Moonshot, is really
characterized
by these three circles.
There's some kind of problem in
the world, or opportunity that
really would affect
a lot of people,
that someone's identified.
There's some kind of
breakthrough technology.
It might sound like science
fiction, but it's available.
Or some new way
of doing something
that we already know
well, in the tech area.
And they've got a radical
solution, a product or service,
or way, that actually
could scale in the world.
So even if you took something
like a self driving car.
The problem is, of course,
you know, billions of people
wasting time in traffic.
Safety.
Texting and driving.
All those kinds of issues--
fuel efficiencies--
a really serious
problem worth solving.
The breakthrough
technology today,
are things like real time
sensors, the level of mapping
we have, kind of robotics, et
cetera-- that would allow us
to, in a radical way,
have a car drive itself,
in the current system.
Not some kind of special route.
So that's the Moonshot
of the self driving car.
So today, we're going to hear
from four extraordinary teams.
The first one is
actually a team of 10,
so it's five amazing
people who have moonshots.
And the format is the following,
you want to tell the format?
Yeah, sure.
So we're going to
have each of them
come up on stage, present their
10 minute proposal to you,
which goes through this format,
of what they're working on,
what their breakthrough idea is,
and how they're going to do it.
And then after we
hear from all of them,
what we're going to do is, in
these tables that you guys are
sitting in, to do an interactive
brainstorming session--
we borrowed this
concept from improv,
spend two-thirds of
your time thinking,
'yes, and what else could we
do?' What resources can we
provide?
What people could we connect
these Moonshot Pioneers to,
that are really going to
accelerate how quickly they
can get this out in the world?
And then, spend
some of the time--
A third of the time doing 'Yes,
but.' Does the math add up?
Is the physics right?
Does this make sense?
What are maybe some of the
blind spots or questions that
might not have
been asked before?
So we'll do that for
about 25 minutes,
and then have each of the groups
come back, and report out.
And it's actually the
most fun, interesting part
of this session-- where
we get an explosion
of different directions and
ideas, that come out of this.
MEGAN SMITH: And the thing about
it is, that you may be like,
oh my god, I don't know
anything about these topics.
But the best ideas--
sometimes on your table,
there is going to
be somebody who's
a super expert of the topic, and
somebody who's knows nothing.
And that mix is where
we get the best ideas.
And so, we'll have
enough so that we'll
have two tables per idea.
And they're bringing
more chairs.
They said they'd be here
in about 5 or 10 minutes.
So we'll make another
table back there.
So that's the plan.
And thanks for being here.
And then, we'll
come do report outs.
So, we want to get started.
It's a bit-- the style is kind
of like a short Ted-like talk,
these guys are
going to do, to make
this proposal in the format.
PUNEET AHIRA: We have Sara,
who's joining us right now,
who's going to talk to us about
her vision of how to make food
globally cheap and abundant.
And we've been
working with-- do you
want to come up and get set up?
We've been working with Sara
for the last few months,
and have been so excited
about all of the progress
that she's made.
And so we're so
excited that she's
been able to fly over
here from Nairobi, to be
able to share this
story with you.
And hopefully, they'll
be areas for you guys
to collaborate with, with
this project, as well.
MEGAN SMITH: While
she's setting up--
one of the things that's
interesting in Solve for X,
we've done-- we do a summit with
18 proposals every February,
and then we've 10 of
these mini events.
One at Congress actually,
which was great,
to try to get them moving on
proposals, and stop arguing.
So, one of the areas that
we're always looking for,
because it's 10%
of GDP of countries
is agricultural breakthroughs.
And so, it was
great to find Sara.
SARA MENKER: And actually,
I have a gift for every one.
So I want you guys
to pass this around
and, just take
one tortilla chip.
You've not allowed to
have more than one.
And don't eat it.
Sorry.
It'll defeat the purpose of
what I'm trying to achieve.
I guess, as it's
being passed around,
I want you guys to have
that tortilla chip as a way
to contextualize
the conversation,
I want us all to have.
But you know, show of
hands, just for the sake
of show of hands, who has
a smartphone of any kind?
100% of the room.
So a decade ago, smartphones
that we have today,
with the functionality
that we have,
would have been over two
times expensive, if not more.
So we've managed to half the
price of the devices we use.
The tortilla chip,
in your hand however,
has gone up by two
and a half times.
So the one thing we need to
live with, and survive with,
is the one thing that we've
managed to not solve for.
And how expensive food has
gotten and will continue
to get, is a very
scary proposition.
So by way of background,
I'm Ethiopian.
I was raised in
Ethiopia in the 80s,
at the peak of the food crisis.
So my natural transition was
to become a commodities trader
on Wall Street.
Now, in 2008,
there was something
that happened in the
commodities markets.
Oil hit $150, and global
food prices and grain prices
hit what was an all time high.
At that point in
time, I freaked out.
And my freaking out was
really driven by a fear
that 20 years down
the line, there's
no way we're going to be able
to afford food, personally.
So I just kind of developed an
obsession around agriculture.
I was trading
energy at the time,
so there wasn't a
reason why I should
be obsessed with this problem,
other than I knew the markets.
And that obsession eventually
led me to quit my job in 2012,
to go down this path
of trying to help
make food cheap and abundant.
Now when I left, it was
the beginning of 2012,
and what I didn't know
was later that year,
we'd hit new highs
in grain prices.
And little did I know that
the country I had chosen
to move to, which was
Kenya-- so I left New York,
and moved to Kenya-- would be
hit particularly hard by it.
See, what happened in
2012 is, in 2011, Kenya
had experienced a drought, that
it was barely recovering from.
And as it was
starting to recover,
a disease had been
discovered-- a crop
disease had been discovered.
And just as that disease
started to spread,
droughts in the US and
Russia hit simultaneously.
Now the US and Russia are
two of the world's largest
grain exporting countries.
What that meant, was that
Kenyan corn prices went
from being below
the global average,
to being well above the average.
And it kept getting
worse, because what
happened was
policymakers then adopted
a policy of reinstating
a 50% import tax on corn.
Now corn, in the US
might mean something
like tortilla chips, high
fructose corn syrup, ethanol.
Corn in Kenya, is what
Kenyans eat every single day.
It provides almost half of
the calorie requirements
for the country.
And the poorest quarter in the
country, spend about a third
of their income
on that one grain.
Now when I graduated
from college,
I remember being
told to spend about--
to expect to spend about a
third of my salary on rent.
So now imagine spending a third
of your total income, not all
your food requirements,
but on a single good.
See, there's no
more room for error,
in the way we think
about food, and the way
we think about food prices.
And we're already at a stage
when we have no room for error.
And areas like the one I
gave as an example in Kenya,
unfortunately happen
all over Africa.
And it happens not
because policymakers
are malicious or malintention.
It happens because there's
a lack of information
and clarity, in the type
of information needed,
to make the policy
decisions being made.
Now fast forward in where
we're going to, as a world.
We are expected to be 9.1
billion people by 2050.
As a wealthier population, we're
expected to need 70% more food.
Because we consume a lot
more, than we actually
growing as a population.
So in this space where
there's no room for error,
you have this happening
with population.
And to top it off, you
have climate change.
The frequency of
droughts, floods,
wind-related crop damage
has grown exponentially--
such that, actually figuring
out agricultural production,
and productivity, has
become impossible.
So what happens next?
We've got it--
it's clear we have
to increase food production.
How does that happen?
It's got to happen
in one of two ways.
We're either going
to have to start
growing more food
on the plots of land
that we're growing food
in, so increasing yield.
Or we're going to have
to plant new land.
Now I'll argue, as much as I
said about Africa, that Africa
is actually the place
for that to happen.
Not only does it have the
largest swath of arable land
remaining in the world-- four
times the amount in the US,
planted across the US today.
It also has such low yields,
that if in 2012, African corn
yields were just equivalent
to the world average,
we could have actually
increased corn production
by 12% that year.
It was a 2% reduction in
corn production globally,
that actually led to
that sort of price spike.
So imagine what a 12% increase
in production can happen.
So the next question you
ask is, so how are we
going to solve this mess?
And how do we go
about doing that?
That's where we like
to think of the work
that we're doing as being
that Moonshot around how
to address
productivity in Africa.
We've created a real time,
basically tracking application,
that allows all sorts of users,
from policymakers to traders,
to basically visualize and
analyze all sorts of data
around agriculture.
So the application
currently, basically-- it's
not that the data isn't
available by the way,
in terms of what
policymakers are using.
It's that it's
highly disaggregated.
It's comes in multiple formats.
And nobody knows where it sits.
So what ends up
happening, is that a user
doesn't know which
source to tap,
for what piece of information.
So what we've done is we've
created a blank slate.
It's a blank slate that
actually sucks in and aggregates
all sorts of data-- over 40,000
indicators, that basically look
at all sorts of analytics around
Africa, African agriculture,
but also global agriculture.
So metrics from
emissions, to rainfall,
to vegetation, to production.
So what ends up happening is, a
continent where 30% of its GDP
comes from agriculture--
less than 1%
of outstanding bank loans today
are to the agricultural sector,
the reason is capital
is not available.
So what we're trying
to do, is basically
make the data available that
lets capital be unleashed.
So in this context, now you
take your tortilla chips--
and I want everybody to
imagine being a credit
officer for farmers in Nigeria.
And you have and
Nigerian cassava farmer
that comes to your office.
In the past, the way decisions
are made is a yes or no,
and oftentimes,
it ends with a no.
What we are envisioning,
is a future,
where if you are
a credit officer,
you have a tool that
lets you go in and look
at all sorts of parameters,
around say, supply
and the supply of
certain different crops
that are important in Nigeria.
So to give an example,
tomatoes-- Nigerians
are actually one of the largest
importers of tomato paste,
and wheat.
And so, it allows you to go
in, and create this real time
tracking system, that
allows you to look
at a series of these
indicators, in such a way
that you can generate
a series of charts.
Now, I've kind of fast
tracked this process,
so that we can get to
what we actually track.
So we track everything
from-- so imagine
you have a cassava farmer
coming in for a loan.
Now, cassava to
Nigerians is what's
equivalent to the corn story
that I told you about in Kenya,
they eat it every single day.
Now, as you can see,
cassava production--
if you're a credit
officer, you have
to understand the volatility
in production cycles.
That you'll see in 2009,
there was a cassava crisis.
You'll want to understand
why that happened,
and how you can think
of that differently.
That actually
happened because there
was flooding in the core cassava
producing regions of Nigeria
at the time.
Now what ends up happening when
you have that sort of rainfall,
and that sort of drop
in cassava production,
is you have a drastic
import of wheat.
Wheat is the alternative to it.
And the US provides 80%
of the wheat into Nigeria.
And so you can track vegetation.
So you can actually
watch how vegetation
in a particular region evolves.
By being able to look
at, and dynamically
visualize all this data
that is incredibly complex--
this is not coming
from a single source.
Each one looks at
various sources
to extrapolate what the
true number should be.
Because no one source
actually tells us what it is.
And so what we're
hoping, is that this tool
becomes the tool that allows
us to basically unleash capital
into African agricultural
markets, to increase the yields
so that farmers can
basically produce more
on the existing plots of land,
which then feeds into more
investment going into all
that other arable land
that I discussed, which
then leads to abundant food,
and hopefully cheap food.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: OK, so a quick
question for Sara before you
go down, and then we'll
take the next one up.
So we're going to
go to brainstorming,
and there's going
to be two tables who
are going to work on this idea.
So in addition to all
the ideas that they think
of, whatever they think
of, two thirds yes
and-- what kind of distro,
technology, partners,
money, other ideas that
you guys can think of,
that would help this idea.
And then, one third
yes but, meaning
like, what are your
critiques and challenges
you think are there,
and some ideas there.
Is there any set of things, one
or two things that you really
need help on right now, that
you know, as you are building?
SARA MENKER: As
we're building, well,
there's two things
I can think of.
One is, we just actually
finished our first fund raise,
and we're out there hiring all
sorts of talent from front end,
to back end, to machine learning
engineers-- we need people.
And the second,
is the tool that I
showed you, which is the
visualization around satellite
imagery, and weather data,
everything we've done
is basically, allow
it to be animatable.
So a user gets to
curate their experience
and get to zoom in to
a particular region.
And then say, I want to
understand the 10 day
average in this
particular region,
versus the 10 day average there.
And so when you're running
a series of computations
on images that are
varying anyway,
that are coming in daily, or
varying anywhere from being
50 meter squared to you
know, 100 meter square,
you run into all
sorts of challenges,
in terms of giving
it to the user.
So we're thinking about ways
of optimizing that further--
MEGAN SMITH: To
simplify, and enhance--
SARA MENKER: Yes,
simplifying that process.
MEGAN SMITH: --and figure
out how to interact.
OK.
SARA MENKER: Yeah, so
we're on geospatial.
MEGAN SMITH: OK, super.
All right, thank you.
Next up is a really
interesting idea
around environmental
data and impact.
And Randy, I just love
when, a lot of times
we think about China, and
we hear terrible stories,
scary stories about environment.
And you guys are such a hopeful,
and inventive, and ingenious
story from China,
of what you've done.
And so I look forward
to everybody hearing
what you guys are proposing.
LIU CHUNLEI: OK thank you.
Hi, everybody.
Good afternoon.
I'm Lui Chunlei,
from Shanghai, China.
My topic is How to support
the Environmental Protection
information technology in China?
This is our website.
OK I think many guys
know China is facing
one the most serious
environment issues.
Billions of people are impacted
by this, such as water.
This is the from
new, the [INAUDIBLE].
The water quality
of most of the river
are the worst level in China.
And also, the ground water
is a polluted heavily.
For air, more than
1,200,000 people
died earlier due to the
air pollution in China.
You can see Shanghai is in haze.
And the farmland.
More than 50 million
acres of farmland
are heavily polluted in China.
We know the environment
issue is very, very serious.
This is also an example,
the haze of days in 2013.
We know, almost everyday
we can find the [INAUDIBLE]
from the news paper, or the TV.
But we are not sure,
first for citizens,
they're not sure what exactly
is the environment around him.
And how to resolve the
pollution issue in a rapid way,
because you know there
is some relationship
between the government
and the factory.
It's not so easy to
resolve this issue.
So this is why I left
Alcatel-Lucent-- I worked there
for more than eight
years-- to start this job.
I want to help people
in a foreign way.
Out of our million users, you
can find [INAUDIBLE], how to,
through maps, how to help
him, and to resolve something.
He wants an apartment.
So he search one
real estate website,
and found this apartment is OK.
But he want to know
whether it is safe or not.
Then he could go to the
danger map, and to search.
Input the address, and search.
And then he found that
there are many-- not
many-- for some site, there are
some pollutions issues wrong.
So he need to
reconsider this choice,
and he need to try again.
After sometimes searching,
he found [INAUDIBLE] is OK.
But of some amounts,
he found that the water
released some bad materials.
So he bought a water
testing kits [INAUDIBLE],
and he started to
sample the water.
The results was varying.
So he upload this result
with the smartphone
onto the [INAUDIBLE] map.
And shared this map
to his neighbors,
and also [INAUDIBLE].
Then the neighbors gather
together, and have a meeting.
They decided to walk
along the river,
to find the cause,
why this is polluted?
Why is this [INAUDIBLE]?
And finally, they
found one factory,
releasing the pollution water
directly without any deals.
They put the exact
position on the danger map.
And they searched
the number the EPB,
and tried to push them
to stop this factory,
to stop this pollution.
But it's not so easy.
Just [INAUDIBLE], there's
a complex relationship
between the government and
the factory for some tax,
or for other reasons,
corruption and so on.
So they need to continue,
they need to go on, to push,
and go on to such,
many more pollutions.
Now this is the current
danger map, they can help,
it can help.
It can help to found some
of the pollution around it.
And to gather the
neighbors, to [INAUDIBLE].
And now, they are more big
companies, also in the world ,
such as Alibaba.
The prompt there, [INAUDIBLE].
And water test kits
to their employees.
So last year, they had
tested the 420 locations
across 28 provinces.
And also, more medias
and foundations
involved, such as Southern
Weekly, [INAUDIBLE] DFDaily,
and the SEE foundation.
And also, there are many
NGOs are using this tool
to identify these
pollutions and recourse.
But citizens think it
is not good enough.
So the need better services.
So we are planning the
following features.
Not only now, whether
there are pollution,
there are factories,
but know exactly
is there any record
for the pollution,
and what the realtime
water or gas is released
and whether it
exceeded the threshold.
With this information published,
so the real estate developers,
many of them are
millionaires or billionaires,
can help control the pollution,
because this ill impact
the price to their apartment.
Also, currently there are many
data controlled by government,
but they didn't publish
or not a convenient way.
So we needed to
summit the application
to open it, and show them,
and analyze and show them
to the citizens, in
a convenient way.
Also, they need-- maybe you
have the air quality and water
quality, with real
time history and trend.
And also, we need
to know if there
any good things around
us, not only bad things.
So we can give people some hope.
And also comments
about the environment
from the local citizens.
When he found some
pollution issue,
he can share this information
to also NGOs and medias.
Because this, they
will help them
to fix this, to
resolve this issue.
And we will present the
phone number, email, Weibo,
and Weixin, in the EPB.
So they can contact the
partners in a really rapid way,
to set up the [INAUDIBLE].
And if the citizen contribute
to a local environment
reach some criteria,
you will get some gifts
from some big company.
This company-- this big
companies, [INAUDIBLE]
their brand, and want to make
of their brand environment
friendly.
So in this way,
also the employees
of these big companies
can be involved.
It's millions, I think.
And in China, there
are also many NGOs
for environment protection.
We will design a
mechanism, so they
can be involved in
a more deeper way.
So we can support each other,
and also impact their fans.
The draft plan-- a new,
open interactive danger
maps with solid data, will be
built in the following way.
Because China, there
are many provinces.
So we want to run it this way.
And then we want to implement,
with this architecture.
So, with the air quality,
water quality, land quality,
and the pollution sources.
All data will be collected
into the open DB.
Open means open to the
third party and you.
And other stakeholders.
And then, with the
EPB and the web,
the information can easily
be shared, or feed back
to the government,
factory, and the reporters.
So, citizens can know the
overall environment around us,
and also, action, to
change them in a rapid way.
Technically, we will implement
this with such technologies,
internal DB, node.js, mirrors,
and Hybrid App, binaries,
and so on.
That's the technical
architecture.
Yeah, that's all.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PUNEET AHIRA: Fantastic.
Thank you so much, Liu.
I think what's amazing about
this story, is how much
attention it's
gotten within China.
Jack Ma, who is the CEO
and founder of Alibaba,
has personally been
supporting this,
trying to get all
of his employees
to be much more
environmentally active.
And this just provides an
outlet for all of that,
to become so much more
exposed and transparent.
Liu, if you have-- I wanted
to get your perspective, what
are the biggest
challenges that you're
facing that this group
can brainstorm about,
during our breakout session?
LIU CHUNLEI: The
first one is the data.
The environmental data
is [INAUDIBLE] for China,
such as farmland.
Pollution data is
a secret of nation.
So we can not get it.
And there are also
many data [INAUDIBLE]
that is not so easy
to dig, to analysis.
So we need some way to
many, many application,
for to government,
to open the data.
This is the first one.
I think the second
one is we need
more support from
financial partners.
There are many
jobs needed to do.
But we need more
support, I think, yeah.
PUNEET AHIRA: Excellent.
Thank you so much again.
LIU CHUNLEI: Yeah, thank you.
PUNEET AHIRA: Our next-- sorry,
another round of applause,
if you--
[APPLAUSE]
Our next speaker is
Professor Sarah Bergbreiter,
from the University of Maryland.
And she's got a
fascinating proposal
that she's going to
present, on the use
of micro robotic
platforms, and all
of the incredible
applications it
has for many of the
challenges that we face.
SARAH BERGBREITER: All right.
Thank you very much.
So this is the Minnesota I-35
bridge, about seven years ago
in 2007.
This bridge supported over
140,000 cars each day.
When the bridge collapsed,
there were over 150 casualties,
including about 13 deaths.
To avoid scenes like
this, which are far, far
more common in the
developing world,
the current solution is
to do something like this.
Basically hang a couple
guys under a bridge,
with some lights, looking at
the bridge structure, and joints
and sure making sure everything
is structurally sound.
And honestly, you're
probably lucky if this
happens every couple years.
In the developing world, you're
lucky if it happens at all,
I think.
So we'd like to come up with
a better solution for that.
Another thing that you
see on TV way too often,
is scenes like this.
So this is the aftermath of the
New Zealand earthquake in 2011.
You see a bunch of guys
searching through some rubble,
trying to find survivors,
after this rather catastrophic
earthquake.
And you have even more
catastrophic earthquakes,
like in Haiti and the like.
But these enormous
piles of rubble,
and how do you get through them?
How do you find survivors?
We'd like to be able to create
more scenes like this one,
where rescuers found a four
month old baby, shortly
after the Japanese tsunami.
So what kind of infrastructure--
what kind of platform
can we use to help us solve
both of these problems?
Things like civil infrastructure
monitoring, and searching
for survivors after
something like an earthquake.
I'm going to propose this guy.
This is an ant.
Or more appropriately,
this guy, right here.
This is a robotic
version of an ant,
that we're working on in my lab
at the University of Maryland.
So I'll talk a little bit
more about this guy later.
And I have it with
me, in my bag,
if anybody would like to see
it a little bit later, as well.
But these things can do some
fascinating things, right?
We have some amazing
existence proofs
in biology of what
these insects can do.
Ants can build bridges out of
themselves, for other ants.
Really incredible stuff.
You've all seen ants carry
Cheerios or Potato chips off
of your picnic table, I'm sure.
Much to your chagrin, right?
Termites, which are very
much on the same scale,
build these incredible
structures, up to eight meters
high-- effectively well
ventilated, air conditioned,
apartment buildings
for other termites.
Right?
So impressive structures.
I don't think
anybody would argue
that something
the size of an ant
can get through
some of that rubble,
and has the appropriate sensors,
and communications on board,
notify first responders
after an earthquake.
And the ants and
insects this size
can also make themselves
comfortably at home,
on fairly complex
structures like a bridge.
So what do we need to do in
order to engineer this ant?
What do we need to do to
create an engineered robot ant?
Or probably more appropriately,
bunches of these robot ants.
So we can need
buckets full of them.
So I'll briefly go through
some of the big challenges
that I see.
So, one is mobility.
I'm really small.
Everything else
around me is big.
How do I get through that?
I also need
mechanisms, and motors,
in order to support
that mobility.
And I need them to be
robust, and efficient,
in order to get
through these things.
I need the power, the control,
the integration, in order
to add sensors, communication
potentially, in order
to be able to localmote, and
get through these environments.
And perhaps even more
importantly, in the end,
I need group behavior.
So I can do impressive
things like this,
which you've all seen probably.
In this case, a bunch of
ants found a tasty treat,
a dead grasshopper.
They're managing to extricate
it from these dead leaves,
and slowly move it
towards their nest.
And you can see this
incredible locomotion
through this rather
rough terrain.
Imagine your Roomba
at home, trying
to do this kind of
same thing, right?
Horrible.
Like it sees a step,
and it's like, ah!
So we want to be able to
do something like this.
So for the sake
of time, I'm going
to focus on a couple
of these challenges.
We're working on all
of them in my lab.
And I'm happy to talk
a little bit more
about some of the
other ones as well.
But I'll focus a little bit on
mobility mechanisms and motors.
So first, mobility.
So this is another insect.
You already saw the ants
moving through these things.
This is from across the bay at
Bob Full's lab at UC Berkeley,
watching cockroaches get through
this incredible environment,
right?
If you and I tried to get
through an environment
like this, right?
We're looking down, making
sure our foot is stable,
before we take our next step.
Cockroaches don't
do any of this.
The mechanisms in their
leg provide the control
and the stability,
so that they can
run through these
environments at high speeds.
And part of what
allows them to do that,
is a combination of
rigid materials, which
is what we traditionally used
to make robots, but also soft,
[INAUDIBLE], elastic materials,
that give them the damping,
to enable them to do this.
Another interesting
method of locomotion,
if you're really
small, is jumping.
And there's all sorts of
interesting jumping insects
out there.
In this case, they store
energy in effectively,
a spring, and release
that very quickly, to get
the high power
they need to jump.
And then once again, it's a
combination of rigid materials
and soft materials, that
enable them to do things
like jump out of water,
which is quite impressive.
So our big contribution has
been to add soft materials
to traditional micro
fabrication processes.
So micro fabrication allows
us to get structures down
to microns in size-- right?
Your hair is typically 50
to 100 microns in diameter,
for reference.
And in this case,
we can also take
advantage of a lot of the
sensors and actuators,
that people are you
doing in Silicon,
with our future micro robots.
So what do we do to do
this, to incorporate
these soft materials,
is we effectively
have a micro molding process.
We etch trenches into
our silicon wafer.
We refill that with a
rubber, silicone elastomer,
which is the blue here.
We etch more trenches, to
create our silicon features.
And we can do this, across
a whole silicon wafer,
so we can make thousands
of these at once--
which is the cool thing.
So we can make some
interesting structures.
But you ask, OK,
so this is cool,
but how do I get my robot?
So this is an interesting
little jumping mechanism
that we put together.
This video, this whole thing
is about four millimeters
on a side.
This video is very freaky,
to any [INAUDIBLE] person,
or micro fabrication
person, because you're not
used to seeing strains like this
in traditional micro machining
materials.
So the basic idea
behind this is,
I'm going to take the structure
of four millimeters in size,
compress it, and release that
energy, in order to get a jump.
So there's no motors
on this, no power yet.
This is actuated in a very
fancy method, we have in our lab
called graduate
student with tweezers.
So what we're going to
see in the next video,
is a black, fuzzy dot
flying through the air.
So this is a very
small, black, fuzzy dot.
This is Erin, the graduate
student in question.
And what you see here, is this
little four millimeter device
jumping almost 100
times it's own length.
But once again, no motors, no
power or anything like that.
But incredibly robust-- it
actually bounces on the table.
It's survives over and over,
and over, until we eventually
lose it, when it
flies off the screen.
How are we going to
actuate these things?
Well, this is some of the motors
that we're doing in our lab.
They have high power densities--
higher than insect flight
muscle, in fact.
But they're still very hard to
integrate with the mechanisms
that I just showed you, in
order to really study locomotion
at this scale.
So we're going to cheat.
We're going to put
magnets in here right now.
And this is controlled with
an external magnetic field.
But you can see, I have this
compliant elastomer joint.
I've got a magnet
embedded in there.
And this is effectively,
a little robot leg.
So this would be part of
what I showed you earlier,
in this little
micro robot mock up.
One of the interesting things
about locomotion at this scale,
is that we don't really
know how to do it yet.
So we have good
models for everything
from a cockroach on up.
If you want to know
how we run, you
can basically think
of a mass on a spring.
And we compress
this spring as we
land, and release that
energy as we take off.
Everything does this.
As you get smaller, the forces
in interacting with the ground
are going to start to
affect your locomotion, more
potentially than your mass
and your inertia-- which
is very tiny, when
you're this small.
So this particular one
is not working quite yet.
But we have ones at
centimeter cubed,
to show you what these
things actually look like,
when they're moving around.
So these guys, we've moved at up
to 10 body lengths per second.
So they can move quite quick,
and that's really only limited
by our test set up.
So this gives you an idea
of how the magnetic field is
controlling these guys.
So we can actually start
studying how we ultimately
want to locamote, to solve
some of these challenges.
But ultimately, we want to
add our sensors and control,
and everything on board too.
So this guy is about
four millimeters,
by four millimeters, by
seven millimeters in size.
It has capacitors for power.
It has a transistor for control.
And it has a light
sensor on board.
So it's going to react to
light in its environment.
And the actuator
in this case-- this
is done by my student,
Wayne Churaman,
who's also at the
Army Research Lab.
The actuator, we don't need to
necessarily be bio inspired.
The actuator is an energetic.
It goes boom.
So in this case, we can micro
fabricate small, little pixels
of this energetic material.
And we can set them
off independently,
from multiple jumps or jumps
in different directions.
And the cool thing about
this, is that we can actually
combine this then, with
our robot that I showed you
earlier, put it on
the belly of this.
And we can effectively have
our little micro rocket robot
for jumping.
So the next video, one
of my favorite videos,
you see this thing jump up--
the big flash at the beginning,
this is at 1,000
frames per second,
and it flies through the air.
So, pretty, pretty
cool, I think, at least.
So I think you have some idea
of how we can kind of jump
around, crawl around
these big structures,
or where we're going
with that, at least.
But they're certainly not
limited-- these robotic insects
are certainly not
limited to those ideas.
Imagine like,
something even a larger
than the fantastic, voyage
vehicle, for robotic surgery.
Either in the US, or in
the developing world,
you could do some really
fascinating things with that.
Or imagine, if you can
combine sensors and actuators,
and mechanisms in
very small packages,
maybe you can create Luke's
hand from "Star Wars"
versus the most advanced,
prosthetic hands
that we have today.
Or one of the big problems with
these earthquake disasters,
is not necessarily
the disaster, itself,
but the humanitarian disaster
that happens afterwards.
So imagine building
temporary housing
with lots of little robots,
like our termite mounds.
Or even radically changing
the construction industry
with this.
So this gives you
some idea of some
of the possibilities
of things that I
think we could do
with small robots.
And I think we're kind of on
the verge of really pushing
this area out there.
And so I think it's a
pretty fantastic Moonshot.
And I thank you for your time.